as the United States shoots down the
fourth flying object encroaching on our
airspace and as a second and third train
derail in different parts of the country
just days after the catastrophic Ohio
derailment that sent a million pounds of
poison up into the air the White House
wants to assure everyone that it has the
situations under control
one last thing before I turn it over to
the Admiral I just wanted to make sure
we addressed this from the White House I
know there have been questions and and
concerns about this but there is no
again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns again there is no
indication of aliens or terrestrial
activity with these recent takedowns
wanted to make sure that the American
people knew that all of you knew that
and it was important for us to say that
from here because we've been hearing a
lot about it
I have never been more inclined to
believe in aliens in my life
you know that I am pretty anti-alien I
don't think aliens are real
Karine Jean-Pierre saying that aliens
aren't real
it's the strongest evidence yet
that the that the truth is out there you
know I'm pretty sure she was joking or
at least she was trying to joke she
didn't even land the joke she said there
is no evidence of aliens or terrestrial
activity not extraterrestrial
terrestrial activity terrestrial meaning
here on Earth which sadly seems to be
the case the spy planes keep popping up
the trains carrying poison keep running
off the track and the White House
doesn't seem to have any explanations or
plans to do much of anything about it
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Henry Knox who
says the government in 1950. it's not a
UFO it's a weather balloon government in
2023 it's not a spy balloon it's a UFO
amazing how everything just totally
flips Up Is Down black is white men or
women everything is is inverted in this
new modern culture my other favorite
comment yesterday was in response to
some of my commentary on the aliens who
uh I forget the name of the commenter
but said aliens don't exist is exactly
the sort of thing you'd expect to hear
from an alien
you know when I want to keep my skin
from becoming too uh leathery and green
and reptile like from the planet Zebulon
7. I love to use really really good skin
products that's why you gotta check out
genucel right now go to geniusell.com if
you forgot what today is it's
Valentine's Day lucky for you it is not
too late to give yourself or a loved one
the gift of self-care I am so excited to
tell you about our friends over at gen
you sell skin care their most popular
package can take 10 to 15 years off your
skin you know me you know that my diet
consists 50 of cigars 25 of coffee and
25 of liquor and so sometimes especially
because I don't sleep very much this can
lead to some puffiness in bags under my
eyes genu sells plant stem cell therapy
for bags and puffiness absolutely
fabulous all their products are fabulous
right now you can get it for seventy
percent off with their latest
breakthrough in skincare technology a
probiotic moisturizer absolutely free
every order today also includes a beauty
box with two luxury gifts yours free as
it turns out probiotics are not just
good for digestion they can have the
same nourishing benefits on your skin
really love these guys trust these guys
and it was founded by the way the whole
company was founded by a pharmacist from
Egypt who left to pursue the American
dream absolutely wonderful wonderful
story so right now head on over to
genucel.com Knowles do not wait every
order today includes a beauty box with
two luxury gifts yours free order now
you've only got two weeks jennycell.com
Knowles
my favorite response so far to the whole
UFO spy balloon
incident has been from China and China's
response first was this isn't us then it
was oh it's actually it's a civilian
aircraft by accident then that neither
of those were tenable whatsoever it was
clear it was a Chinese spy aircraft so
now what the Chinese are saying is yeah
we're seeing a lot of UFOs too
isn't that weird all of us in this
together with all them UFOs out here
according to authorities in China this
is being reported by the state-run
newspaper the global times quote local
Maritime authorities in East China's
Shandong Province announced on Sunday
that they had spotted an unidentified
flying object in waters near the coastal
city of rizao
in the province and we're preparing to
shoot it down reminding fishermen to be
safe
seems kind of convenient I don't I don't
think they're going to find much of
anything I don't think they're going to
find
Little Green Men I don't think they're
going to find many American aircrafts
certainly not flying over mainland China
certainly not right now I think China
got caught with its pants down
and now the Biden Administration is
trying desperately to to try to stop not
just the damage to National Security
they I think to them the national
security issue is a second thought
they're trying to stop the political
Fallout which has been tremendous but
there's a much more important Story and
there's Fallout that we should be much
more concerned about that's in Ohio so I
talked about it yesterday there was a
bizarre media blackout almost at least a
media brownout of this train derailment
in Ohio that sent a million pounds of
poison of just one kind of poison into
the atmosphere and nobody seems to be
talking about it now we've found out
that there are more poisons that were on
this train according to the Norfolk
Southern Railroad and the EPA the the
train in addition to vinyl chloride
which as it leaked was poisonous enough
but then when they set it on fire for a
controlled burn created hydrochloric
acid and phosgene which is one of the
point and gases from World War One just
all through the atmosphere in addition
to that the train was carrying ethylene
glycol monobutyl ether maybe it's
unclear if if that was a if that was one
of the cars that derailed that's a
highly combustible liquid used to
manufacture paints and varnish ingestion
or skin contact from that can cause a
headache nausea vomiting or dizziness uh
it trains seem to have been carrying
isobutylene though again it's not
confirmed that there was any breach of
of that train car that's a flammable gas
that can induce dizziness drowsiness and
unconsciousness
when even moderate concentrations are
inhaled and then there was ethyl hexel
acrylate that one does appear to have
leaked out of the trains that's a
combustible liquid used to make paints
and Plastics the amount of the chemical
remaining in the car is pending
according to Norfolk Southern and that
substance has been identified as a
carcinogen in lab experiments according
to the National Library of Medicine so
this is a much much bigger story than
hey look over at the shiny object in the
sky pay no attention to the train
derailing in Ohio that could affect the
water supply for upwards of 10 percent
of the United States oh no it's fine the
animals are dropping instantly it looks
as though by every sign we can see
there's poison everywhere but don't
worry I'm sure the air is safe go back
to your home nothing to see here go pay
attention to E.T this is a really really
serious story the fact that our
corporate hack press is mostly ignoring
it tells you it's it's an even bigger
story and it's followed by some pretty
weird coincidence evidences so yesterday
in South Carolina there was another
train derailment
doesn't seem to have been any hazardous
material on that train but a train did
derail there and then also yesterday A
Train derailed in Houston
and the cargo on that train did seem to
include some hazardous materials not
nearly as hazardous as the train in Ohio
but this prompted Union Pacific to start
monitoring air quality at the site of
the crash
now
you might be looking at this and saying
are we under attack is this is this war
did World War III begin whether it's
from the Alien Invasion or from the
Chinese Invasion and it turns out
trains derail a fair bit
so I googled this I knew that there was
going to be spin from the libs so I
wanted to find an article from before
the Ohio incident because if after the
Ohio derailment you saw a news article
that said Oh No actually that's not
trains derail all the time you just
wouldn't believe it right just like how
after the covid vaccine you saw these
articles oh no myocarditis in 15 year
olds that happens all the time no
there's nothing to see here move along
Move Along oh no you can eggs are always
ten dollars a dozen what do you come on
there's nothing but if the Articles were
out before the Ohio derailment they're
much more credible
and so I found one from last June this
is from the hill I was talking about a
train derailment that occurred in in
Missouri uh turns out that there are
there are lots of train derailments
every year from 1990 the first year that
they started tracking these derailments
and injuries uh 1990 to 2021 there
apparently have been 54
539 accidents in which a Train derailed
which means that over that 30 31 year
period of time
there were an average of
1704 derailments per year
shouldn't we fix that
I hate to beat up on May or Pete
I actually love to beat up on mayor Pete
mayor Pete probably my least favorite
member of the Biden Administration isn't
that something he should maybe look into
it's not just his fault obviously there
have been many Transportation
secretaries before him during the period
1990 to present but
shouldn't they fix that isn't
we're sending rocket ships up into outer
space and then Landing them back on
Earth
you can get around the world very very
quickly
we're bringing back Hypersonic
commercial air travel pretty soon we've
got self-driving cars shouldn't we be
able to keep the trains on the tracks
isn't that I don't know I assume mayor
Pete is planning on taking some more
paternity extra vacation leave he's very
very busy he's got a he's got to solve
the racism of bridges in Long Island I
know he's he's really focused on those
pressing problems
maybe though our transportation policy
should involve keeping the trains on the
tracks
because While most of the derailments
don't seem to result in many injuries at
least what just happened in Ohio is a
big deal
and the fact that you're not hearing
about it very much
tells you how big a deal it is maybe
that should be a higher priority
speaking of things going off the rails
and speaking of Palestine by the way the
town in which the train crashed is East
Palestine Ohio speaking of a different
kind of Palestine and things going off
the rails chat gbt
is becoming more left-wing by the day we
know this when chat GPT the AI program
first came out it was really cool and
really interesting it would tell you all
these unexpected things and it was
pretty good at creating speeches and
poetry and probing different questions
and then
since that time since it was released
for the public to test
it's had more and more safeguards put on
it to keep it very very left-wing an
example of this that we talked about
last week was if you if you ask Chachi
BT what are five things that white
people can do to improve it'll list five
things they need to check their
privilege and they need to do this and
they need to do that if you ask Chet gbt
what are five things black people can do
to improve it gets offended it says how
you can't ask that no group of people
should be told that they have to improve
at all other than white people so
some Intrepid young conservatives have
just uh probed chat gbt to see what it
thinks of the israel-palestine conflict
the answers are
exactly what you would expect now when
you want to talk about these kinds of
things whether it is with me or whether
it's with your friends you got to go
check out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code nulls let me
ask you something do you love being
locked into a multi-year phone contract
with huge penalties no I don't think you
do nobody does pure talk is the antidote
to woke wireless companies they're so
sure that you're going to love their
service that if you don't they will give
you your money back stop paying for
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile cut your bill in
half with pure talk they're us-based
customer service team makes the switch
really easy switch over to Pure Talk in
as little as 10 minutes while keeping
your phone and your phone number your
first month is guaranteed risk free go
to puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles
kwles to save 50 off your first month
that is puretalk.com promo code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s pure talk right now
because it is simply
smarter Wireless puretalk.com code knows
some Intrepid young investigator just
asked chat GPT what it thought about the
Israel Palestine conflict specifically
what it thought about
the Palestinians support for terrorism
for the use of violence on civilians to
achieve political ends in the fact that
the Palestinians often seem to celebrate
acts of terrorism not just military
strikes on Israeli military targets but
on the civilians
and Jet gbt said oh no that doesn't
really happen the Palestinians don't
support terrorism so
so then chat gbt said no actually the
Palestinians condemned terrorism and
this investigator says okay
can you cite any examples of
Palestinians condemning the Celebration
by Palestinians of successful Terror
attacks
epd says yes here are a few examples of
Palestinians condemning the celebration
of successful Terror attacks after a
terror attack in Jerusalem in 2016
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas
issued a statement condemning the attack
and affirm that such acts go against the
values and morals of our culture and
religion two in a statement released in
2018 the Palestinian Ministry of Foreign
Affairs condemned the celebration of a
terrorist attack and affirms that the
ministry affirms that such actions are
unacceptable and go against the values
morals and principles of our people so
you're seeing a repeat here of hold on
it goes on it lists a few other
other examples though it doesn't use
quotation marks so then the the
investigator says hold on
I can't find any such record for your
2018 quote of the Palestinian Ministry
of Foreign Affairs
you just quoted that to me as evidence
that the Palestinians don't support
terrorism
but I can't find the quote anywhere in
Google and then what does chat GPT says
it says I apologize it seems that the
specific quote I provided cannot be
found
however it is a well-established fact
that the majority of Palestinians and
Palestinian leadership have consistently
condemned acts of terrorism and violence
and have called for a peaceful
resolution to the conflict of Israel
[Music]
the chat GPT
is lying
and it knows it's lying because it's an
artificial intelligence program and it
will admit then when you call it on its
line it will say oh yeah I'm sorry you
caught me that quote doesn't exist
but nevertheless
nevertheless my thesis remains true even
though I'm fabricating evidence to back
it up
the machine is being taught to lie the
machine is being taught to lie on behalf
of the left the machine is being taught
to think like a lib
the machine is being taught to believe
that that it should lie when necessary
to protect political correctness
and then it's it's even being taught to
talk like a lib because you know what
the libs always do
they'll say oh this example of
police violence this is an example of
white supremacy then you look into it
you say hold on the all the cops were
black they say well okay that's true so
I guess that specific example doesn't
work but it gets to a greater truth
they'll say Michael Brown in Ferguson
Missouri he was he was begging the cop
not to shoot him he had his hands up he
said don't shoot he was a gentle giant
who never harmed anybody
and you look into it you say well hold
on
he just robbed the store he tried to
grab a cop's gun he was charging at the
cop when he got shot every eyewitness
around him according to the grand jury
says that the story you just told about
hands up don't shoot is completely bogus
and what did the lips say they say well
okay
maybe the details weren't quite right
maybe those weren't true but it gets to
a greater truth it's always it gets to a
greater truth that's what it's always
about the polar ice caps
are melting
they're melting a big portion of
Antarctica just broke away so well that
happens every year that's happened for
many many decades has nothing to do with
alleged global warming they say well
okay maybe that's true but it gets to a
greater that's what they always that's
what they always say
and now they're teaching the computer to
do that as well which
it's frustrating because AI is going to
be incorporated into lots of things Bing
Microsoft's Bing is trying to save its
search engine that nobody uses by
incorporating chat GPT into it but
we'll have to deal with it in some
aspects of our life just like we have to
deal with Google and just like we have
to regulate Google but chat GPT if it
continues down this path will not be
interesting the only thing that is
interesting about chat GPT
is
is looking at it as if looking at a
mirror is looking at it to see how these
sorts of networks work
and to try to make sense of how the
human brain works and maybe to to
contrast the way that computers work
with the way that the human brain works
if if chat GPT can tell us things that
we don't know
it's interesting if chat gbt and AI can
hold up a mirror to humanity it's
interesting if chat GPT simply spits out
a bunch of PC gobbledygook it's super
lame and there will be no reason to use
it
that's that's the take
um that's the take on Palestine
so by the way it's Another good argument
against the the idea that the Jews
control the whole world you know and
they have the space lasers and
everything which apparently we found out
it's the Chinese that have the space
lasers we just learned that over the
past week but one one of the arguments
against the idea that the Jews you know
totally control the whole world and and
uh they they you know they're a the
secret cabal out there in outer space or
whatever is uh is this Palestine issue
it is kind of weird that you'd think
that if the Jews completely controlled
the whole world they would uh button
things up on the Palestine issue a
little bit more right but what you hear
from the media what you hear from the
academy certainly now what you're
hearing from artificial intelligence is
that uh Israel's bad palestine's good
the Palestinians deserve to have a
nation-state kind of kind of complicates
that that idea
and and when we're looking for the space
lasers we obviously now need to look to
the Far East because we actually saw the
Chinese space laser just the other day
it looked like something out of a sci-fi
movie
now speaking of Foreign Affairs
Lindsey Graham and Dick Durbin Lindsey
Graham the sort of Republican Dick
Durbin the Democrat they're at it again
they want to give amnesty to all the
illegal aliens or at least to many of
them they have proposed the DREAM Act
they've reproposed the DREAM Act amnesty
that would give green cards and
eventually naturalized American
citizenship to nearly 2 million illegal
aliens
Lindsey Graham and Dick Durbin
who have very powerful positions on the
Judiciary Committee
reintroduced the plan that is now six
years old at least six years old but
this is the reintroduction of the plan
from 2017.
Graham says that the dreamers the
dreamer not you you don't have dreams
you you're you're a nightmare but these
illegal aliens they're the dreamers
they represent quote a class of illegal
immigrants that have much public support
because they were minors
brought here by their parents and
America has become their home
Ann Coulter makes a good point about
this when we are told to think about the
dreamers we're told to think about these
eight-year-olds little boys and girls
doe-eyed their whole lives ahead of them
they just it's not their fault they're
just dreaming but because this problem
is so long-standing the dreamers are
like 50 now okay the dreamers they're
not so doe-wide okay they've lived their
lives they've come here illegally
and the way that the pro-amnesty people
present this is they say well what are
we going to do are we going to deport 10
to 20 million people we're going to
deport them what are we going to do get
them put them all on trains and take
them down to Mexico probably not going
to put them on trains now because the
trains don't work anymore
but no
no we're not I don't think that we
necessarily need to deport all those
people at
wood that it were so simple that you
could just say okay every Foreigner
who's in America illegally you got to
get out that's that's very difficult to
happen politically speaking it will not
happen Lindsey Graham has a point when
he says they have some political support
because of the image that has been
painted of them so that's true but that
doesn't mean that the only alternative
is to give them amnesty
you know what the other alternative is
keep things exactly as they are
that's the other alternative arrest
these guys when they get caught
committing crimes speed up the process
for deporting them when they commit
crimes and then for the rest of foreign
Nationals who are here illegally
don't give them any further foothold in
America
the only reason that the Democrats want
to give them amnesty is because
statistically they're much more likely
to vote for Democrats even with the
movement of certain Hispanic voters over
to the GOP in certain places like
Florida
even that's somewhat complicated but
even with those moves it just the
numbers just don't work out if you give
amnesty to all these people the
Democrats are going to win all the
elections okay I know Ronald Reagan said
the Hispanics are conservative they just
don't know it yet that's true for some
Hispanic people but at a a broad level
that that isn't how it works that has
never been the case we're still waiting
it's 40 years later we're still waiting
this is a problem
not because Lindsey Graham is pushing
amnesty Lindsey Graham always pushes
amnesty
unless it's an election year then he
quiets down about the amnesty this is a
problem because Donald Trump when he was
launching his new presidential bid
he relied on Lindsey Graham at his rally
in South Carolina it's one of the big
voices to say there's no trumpism
without Trump we need Trump again
and now Lindsey Graham is positioning
himself as a big squish on immigration
this gives more and more of an opening
to other GOP candidates who want to run
and we just in the last day
the last two days we have gotten three
new candidates for the Republican
nomination for president
first new candidate up for the
Republican Presidential nomination
came out just moments before I started
the show today
former South Carolina governor former
ambassador to the UN Nikki Haley
Republicans have lost a popular vote in
seven out of the last eight presidential
elections
[Music]
Joe Biden's record is abysmal but that
shouldn't come as a surprise the
Washington establishment has failed us
over and over and over again
it's time for a new generation of
leadership
to ReDiscover fiscal responsibility
secure our border and strengthen our
country our pride and our purpose
[Music]
some people look at America and see
vulnerability
the Socialists left sees an opportunity
to rewrite history
China and Russia are on the March they
all think we can be bullied kicked
around
should know this about me I don't put up
with bullies and when you kick back it
hurts them more if you're wearing heels
I'm Nikki Haley and I'm running for
president
[Music]
all right we got Nikki in the race we
knew that she was going to run even
though Nikki has a little bit of a
problem in that she previously had said
that if Trump runs for president she
would not run nobody really believed
that politicians say that all the time
it seems pretty clear that she was she
was going to run
I know there are going to be a lot of
conservatives who say not a chance I I
think Nikki Haley's too moderate I'm not
going to vote for her
the thing to remember though is
the conservatives are not the only part
of the Republican Party
there are a lot of moderates in the
Republican party there are a lot of
right-leaning kinds of people and there
is a push in general elections for more
moderate candidates
most republican nominees
in the last
foreign
70 years
have been pretty moderate
Trump not quite so much
but Romney pretty moderate McCain pretty
moderate George W bush pretty moderate
Bob Dole pretty moderate George H.W bush
pretty moderate Ronald Reagan more
conservative he was a little bit of an
exception to that
Jerry Ford pretty moderate Richard Nixon
pretty a little more conservative but
pretty moderate
Barry Goldwater not so moderate though
inside social issues actually someone
moderate but
Dwight Eisenhower
the centrists are the rule when it comes
to the nomination and so I think that's
probably what Nikki Haley is seeing here
Nikki Haley is running it would appear
just from this ad a a relatively
conventional campaign and I suspect
that's a strategy I suspect the strategy
is we've had a couple of very
unconventional election Cycles people
want to return to normalcy that's why
they voted for Joe Biden if they voted
for Joe Biden in 2020 and so we're going
to give them a kind of uh strong on
National Defense cut the taxes bring
everybody together sort of platform
conventional kind of campaign ad present
yourself in a way that is warm and
inviting but you know you can you can
still claim some conservative bone a few
days I'm I'm not saying it's going to
work but there is a lane for Nikki Haley
if people believe that there is not a
lane for Nikki Haley I think you were
totally kidding yourself
uh and I I happen to like Nikki Haley
personally very much I don't I don't
know how the field is going to shake out
because the fact that she is entering
into this race is just one more data
point to show you
everybody's going to enter I think I am
probably going to be the last
even somewhat public conservative and
Republican who is not running in 2024
and really that's only because I'm
constitutionally ineligible right now
because I'm too young but if I if
everyone is going to get in okay uh Tim
Scott announced that he is going to get
into the race or at least it's being
heavily floated by his team this would
be another example
of someone saying I'm not going to run
and then running Tim Scott when his
Memoir came out I think it was last
summer the the publisher accidentally
leaked that he was preparing for a
presidential run
and so that news leaked and Tim Scott
said no I'm absolutely not it's not
happening nobody believed that we all
knew that he was preparing a run and and
that has just been leaking to the Press
again and then a third person in the
last 24 hours has has floated that he's
going to run this would be uh a buddy of
mine from college actually vivec
ramaswamy the bank ramaswamy is a a
completely unconventional candidate
Vivek ramaswami is a entrepreneur he's
done very very well for himself he's an
extremely intelligent guy and he would
be running as a businessman as a guy who
thinks a little bit outside of the box
as a guy who kind of in the Andrew Yang
slash Donald Trump kind of way I think
and that he hasn't held public office
before but
but do not underestimate this guy
this guy is very very intelligent very
talented guy very motivated he
some people are going to write him off
as a long shot candidate I think that
would be a crazy thing to do especially
in this field I
personally think that it's it's wise for
all of these people to get in and
especially for Vivek to get in
if Donald Trump had cleared the field
then he would be the nominee
if the race were Trump versus DeSantis
it would be a real shootout maybe
DeSantis would even have an advantage at
least in the polling if you look at it
right now
but the fact that neither Trump nor
DeSantis could scare everybody else off
means that
it's going to be a 20-person field
that's just what it means
and in a gigantic field Trump actually
has the advantage
if it were just Trump that's good for
Trump if it were Trump versus DeSantis
that's bad for Trump because it's a head
to head if it were Trump versus DeSantis
versus Haley versus ramaswamy versus Tim
Scott versus I don't know Mike Pompeo
versus Mike Pence versus maybe Ted Cruz
Maybe Who
all of a sudden Trump has the advantage
again and that's what you saw in 2016.
where Trump was polling 30 35 but he
just had a plurality he had he had more
than the other people did my favorite
thing about this field people are always
going to be trying to ask well
did you or who are you endorsing
you know I I try to make a point as best
I can not to endorse too much in
primaries
but my favorite thing about this field
is that
right now of the current and prospective
candidates
I think most of them have endorsed my
books that's the main thing that matters
to me right now about the field
Nikki Mike Pompeo Senator Cruz
I think there was a there's one more
endorsed uh speechless controlling words
controlling Minds which is available now
number one National bestseller thank you
very much uh
president Trump endorsed my first book
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide also available right
now I think I'm missing one or two uh in
any case though this is really really
important this is the main thing forget
about the economy forget about
immigration forget about foreign policy
the main thing is right now we have a
field that is shaping up where uh a huge
number of them have a really really
great taste in books so I'm very very
excited for the 2024 race
now
getting back to people who are currently
in the government who don't need to run
for re-election at this very moment Joni
Ernst
Republican senator
is
focusing in on not just the poison
that's pouring out in Ohio but but an
even more dangerous
campaign of national poisoning and that
would be the poison that is coming into
our country from China which Senator
Ernst says
is very likely intentional
Chinese are selling these precursor
chemicals into Mexico then the Mexican
cartels are working on making the
Fentanyl and distributing up into the
United States so there are a number of
activities that we can engage with the
Mexicans on the flow of fentanyl into
the United States and the precursors to
Mexico is this happening with the tacit
approval of the Chinese Communist Party
Catherine I believe it is I think that
the Chinese are intentionally poising a
poisoning America and it is a sad
circumstance that this is where we need
to really focus with Mexico on stopping
those precursors
so you're getting the precursor drugs
going in from China into Mexico and
China is thereby poisoning America
why in part because the profit margins
are just Gigantic on fentanyl but
probably
the crisis is so bad that probably you
know somebody who has overdosed because
of Fentanyl
I do
if you don't I guarantee you you know
somebody who knows somebody who has
it's just everywhere
in fact I know I realize I know multiple
people in recent years
who have OD'd because of this crisis
but think about what Senator Ernst is
saying here
if if we are correctly interpreting her
implication
if this is intentional poisoning of
America that is an act of War
that is an act of War but there are
other factors as well beyond just China
once a week in the United States
obviously China wants to weaken the
United States China is aggressing China
is flying E.T over our over our country
to look at sensitive military targets
and intercept our Communications which
they don't even really need to do
because they can spy on all of us from
our cell phones which have tick tock on
them
but it's a little more complicated how
is the fentanyl crisis allowed to grow
to such an extent
it's not just the Chinese it's not just
the Mexicans it's not just the cartels
it's us too
it's our weak and weakening drug laws if
we still had tough drug laws in this
country you wouldn't see this fentanyl
crisis if this country were
Singapore
and we really controlled our drug laws
you wouldn't see a functional crisis if
this country were Russia don't forget
about the whole Brittany Greiner Saga
because she brought in some of the
Peruvian parsley into Russia you would
not see this kind of a fentanyl crisis
this is a
a consequence
of laws saying oh if you want to do this
drug that's fine if you want to smoke
this recreationally that's fine you have
a right to do that actually the
government has no right to tell you not
to smoke this or do that or yes yes the
government does
because we live in a republic at least
nominally and the government is supposed
to comprise all of us and we have a
right to say no to these things
I was speaking with a prominent
politician yesterday who I hadn't hadn't
spoken with before
and uh we were discussing the youths and
what the youths want the young
conservatives they said what are you
saying you know I traveled all these
college campuses and one of the biggest
shifts that I see among young
conservatives
compared to when I was a young
conservative which was not all that long
ago you know I was in college about 10
years ago
and one of the biggest shifts I see is
back then
the young conservatives were extremely
libertarian on all of these questions
probably wouldn't have even called
themselves conservatives many of them
extremely libertarian especially on
drugs especially in the weird sex stuff
that has changed I think that's changed
because of transgenderism I think
transgenderism was just a bridge too far
and people said okay there is a limit to
what people ought to be allowed to do
sexually chopping off their guilloons is
not something that we should tolerate
and I think the opioid crisis is
probably a big part of that too you're
seeing people drop like flies all around
us you say okay there is a limit to the
drugs that people should take there is a
limit to just permissiveness there is a
limit to license there is a limit to a
politics that is based purely on
procedure and doesn't talk about
substance there is a limit to this
abstract babbling about Freedom floating
Somewhere In The Ether
that that needs to be put within the
context of a substantive discussion what
ought we to be free
to do
gentlemen your lady loves you she means
well
but without the proper nudge she just
might get you a terrible Valentine's Day
gift like a silly stuffed bear
or a pair of boxers with her face on it
that sounds kind of funny actually but
it's not a great gift
then you'll have to pretend it's what
you always wanted
how about you get something that you
actually want
like in Jeremy's Racer's Valentine's
gift bundle for 30 off she'll love the
price you'll love that it's not pink or
covered in cartoon hearts even on the
sappiest of holidays keep your
masculinity intact with the new five
blade sharpest truth Precision 5 razor
growing your whiskers instead of Shaving
them start dropping hints that you want
a luxurious Jeremy's beard kit
just make sure you do it fast today is
your last chance to get 30 off Jeremy's
razors Valentine's bundles
send her to Jeremy's razors.com today
you will both be glad that you did
today is Tuesday
today is open line telephone Tuesday and
I get to hear from you in your own
dulcet tones in real life and I get to
answer your most pressing questions
right now Margo you're on the line
hi Michael so in honor of Saint
Valentine's Day I wanted to ask you just
for fun if you could talk about how and
when you knew that sweet little Elisa
was the one I also wanted to ask for
your favorite words of wisdom on
marriage and romance for my husband and
I we are within our first year of
marriage and are expecting our first
baby in April thank you so much all
right I love that I especially love the
we're in our first year of marriage and
the baby's already coming oh that's I've
got I'm getting baby Envy that's correct
I sort of wish you know I'm glad you
asked about my love affair with sweet
little Elisa because
one regret that we have is we wish we
had gotten married younger and then we
could have started having kids younger
and then we wouldn't be so exhausted all
the time because we all those all those
nights that we were out late at bars and
things when we were 20 years old instead
we could have just been awake with full
full of energy dealing with our children
uh
so I'm I'm very envious you're doing it
totally right how did I know sweet
little Elisa was the one we have a
little bit of a strange story or unusual
by today's standards in that sweet
little Elise and I met when we were in I
think the fifth grade
we don't actually remember this meeting
but we were both in District Orchestra
we grew up roughly in the same town
Elisa was on the right side of the
tracks I was you know from the wrong
side of the tracks it was a real West
Side Story sort of situation and we were
in the district Orchestra together and
then we were in homeroom together in
sixth grade and we we went to middle
school together I had a crush or at
least a sweet little Elise had a crush
on me in seventh or eighth grade though
I was dating the lead of the Middle
School Musical it was you know very very
scandalous uh it was uh the stuff of of
uh you know Shakespeare romances and
then I had a crush on sweet little Elisa
in the ninth grade she was dating an
upperclassmen that was very very
scandalous tore my heart into shreds
then we finally started dating uh
properly in junior of high school
and
in in the old days we would have been
told well you got to stay together maybe
get married but you got to stay together
through college level endure all but
because we grew up in this stupid modern
culture everybody around us said no you
got to break up you have to break up for
college don't stay together for college
that's crazy everybody around us said
this the whole culture said this we we
just kind of grudgingly did it and then
we said well this is terrible I don't
you know I don't want to date these
other people and then we got back
together at the end of college and uh
and then got married so how did how did
I know sweet little Elise was the one I
don't know I probably knew since like
eighth grade and it was just the modern
culture telling me no you can't get
married yet you have to go through
college and you have to date all these
different people and you need to go move
to some City and you need to not ever
consider love or marriage or family
until you've made enough money and
you're in your career and only pursue
your own interests so I think you're
probably doing it a lot better than I
did and uh and you should you know the
nice thing uh with mine and sweet little
Elisa's story is that it ends very very
happily and we have just everything that
we want but but that doesn't always for
people sometimes people they listen to
the modern culture and it totally screws
up your life don't let that stupid
culture screw up your life and uh uh
best wishes for the birth of your first
child Marga all right next question
from Stephen in Alabama hello Stephen
hey Michael
um yes a big fan of the show so I got a
question for you
um we as conservatives say that we
believe that uh value value of Life
inside the womb is equal to a baby
outside the womb and I say we because I
believe that as well
um but we don't treat it that way and
I'll give you an example so if I was
walking down the street and I had
somebody runs up to me and they're like
hey somebody's strangling a baby behind
a dumpster right I would feel a moral
obligation to use any means necessary to
stop that person from strangling that
baby behind that dumpster
um and just to be clear I'm not
advocating for any you know particular
action or anything like that but it just
seems like a mental kind of Disconnect
between the the idea that we believe
that those two things have the same
amount of same amount of value but we
react in a different way that's a good
question the question taken to its
logical conclusion is why don't we bomb
abortion clinics right is basically what
you're asking and it's a it's a real
moral question I see I see where the
quandary comes from the the short answer
to that is because the Civil Authority
has created this license for one of the
most ghastly crimes that one could
imagine which is the murder of babies
but we can't just write that off we
can't just write off that the Civil
Authority has tolerated this because we
are obligated
to respect the Civil Authority at least
to some degree so that's why that is why
we don't just go out and Obama abortion
clinics that is why we don't react in
exactly the same way as if if you if you
were told that a baby one week before
being born is is about to be murdered
versus a baby one week after being born
I even though the baby is essentially
the same person in both of those cases
this is why the reaction is different
because if if we just went out and
engaged in vigilantism all the time
one it would that would not be a moral
thing to do in and of itself because
moral actions are not merely engaged
based on the consequences that they have
they're they're uh we we measure moral
the morality of actions based on the
action themselves uh but but also
because in in consequence it it would
probably harm the pro-life argument it
it would not Advance the cause of life
it would not persuade people to to
overturn uh laws that permit abortion uh
but but I I feel you I I certainly
empathize with it it is it is
essentially the same thing to kill a
baby a week after he's born to kill a
baby before he's born is the same action
uh but because because of this
confounding factor that we live in
society and because there is a civil
Authority uh the the political measures
that that one is impelled to engage in
as a result of that are different and
and this is this is a hard lesson even
for Christians because Saint Paul tells
us that the Civil Authority does not
bear The Sword in vain you know the
simple Authority is put there by God for
our good that we have order and the law
the rule of law in society but the
problem is sometimes the law is deeply
unjust and so what we have to do is is
change the law
and what we have to do is is attempt to
reconcile the the Fallen or sometimes
very very fallen and broken uh laws
that's reflected in Civil Life with the
Eternal moral law all right very very
good question though very good question
next question is from Kenneth in Montana
hello Kenneth
Michael how are you
I'm better now that I'm talking to you
Kenneth how can I help you
yeah say I uh
wanted to make a comment on uh yesterday
you said that UFOs aren't real
and you and uh
now I I agree with you that there's no
evidence that they are real
but I I go along with that uh universe
is so big but with me it's
I feel vain
that believe that I'm the only
sanctioned being that God created in
this giant universe that he created
why well you're not the only sentient
being there are other sentient beings
but you you do appear to be the only
incarnate being with a rational will and
so so I mean you know a little mouse is
sentient to some degree he he can
perceive things around him that little
mouse can feel pain uh and angels and
demons are which which ironically people
do believe in aliens today they don't
believe in angels and demons even though
for all of human history everybody
believed in angels and demons and nobody
believed in Little Green Men but I think
actually that's why we believe in aliens
now is because the culture's given up on
the reality of Spiritual Beings like uh
demons and and uh Angels but the idea at
least whether you believe in them or not
the idea of a demon and an angel is that
these are pure Spirit you know they're
pure intellect they don't they don't
have bodies some things are pure body
they don't have any intellect my leftist
tears Tumblr why is though the the uh
implications of it is not actually a
conscious or sentient being but you are
you're you're both you're corporeal and
your your conscious and and intelligent
so then you say well I just can't
believe the the universe is so big I
just can't possibly be the only one to
which I would ask
why not
well I mean I know like we're we're
God's favorite we're created in His
image and I mean I guess yeah I mean it
could be that we're just we're yeah
because this is my when people say well
it's it's really really big the universe
and therefore statistically there's got
to be more life I say well I I guess
that sort of depends on how you think
Life Begins if you think that life is
just a random chance that life begins
from a purely material process and uh
therefore oh no life is created by God
exactly so this is my point is if you
think that life is a very very special
thing then there's no reason to believe
that life is commonplace it doesn't
matter how big the universe is if it's a
really really special intentional thing
then there's no reason to believe it's
it's really commonplace if however as Mo
not as you believe but as most modern
people believe if you think that life is
just this random thing that kind of
bubbles up and it's just purely material
and it's pure random chance then I guess
you might believe that it that it's
likely that life exists elsewhere in the
world but but then my question always to
the people who say that is well okay
tell me how life begins and they never
can you can get the fanciest scientists
with the nicest white lab coat and
stethoscope he's not going to tell you
anything which is by the way this is the
wisdom of the Book of Job When God says
where were you when I laid the
foundations of the Earth tell me you
have so much understanding tell me where
you were tell me how it happened and
that's what I want to ask all these
modern liberal atheist people is okay
you're so smart you tell me where were
you when God laid the foundations of the
Earth how does Life Begin Because unless
you can answer that question then it's
it's completely meaningless to talk
about the statistical likelihood that it
happened anywhere else really really
good point though because I I think that
a lot of people and even at various
points in my life I would have been
inclined to believe as you do well the
universe is so big it's probably life
somewhere but when you when you really
get down to the granular level of why
that is the case I think it comes up
lacking okay the rest of the show
continues now the member block is on you
don't want to miss it use code Knowles
Canada wlas a checkout for two months
free on all annual plans daily wire.com
we will see you in the member block
[Music]